jamie thank you the buccaneers put on a
defensive show on their way to victory
last night
in part thanks to defensive tackle and
domican sue what a night he joins us
from tampa
good morning to you dama kinsu we all
stayed up late to watch the game morning
how are you
not as good as you yes yes we all stand
up to
watch the game and dominican it seems
like you guys were high-fiving each
other when there was still four minutes
left on the clock so
please take us down to the field take us
down to what you guys were thinking and
feeling
go yeah we were excited the entire time
knowing we had an opportunity and we
really gave them a lot of points the
first time around so
we just knew we had to come out and stay
in front of them as a secondary and
defensively up front just get after that
quarterback and that was our mission
throughout the entire game and i got
some opportunities to get after him as
well as shaq barrett and a bunch of
other guys on our defensive line so
super excited about what we were able to
do patrick mahomes said they took away
our deep stuff they took away the
sidelines
they played a heck of a game defensively
it's maybe one of the worst games
he's ever had i mean that's an
incredible achievement
what did you guys talk about going in
coach bowles is amazing coach and really
he set up an amazing game plan and we
wanted to execute that from a standpoint
and make sure mahomes couldn't get out
to his right
forcing him into his left making tough
throws whether he's on one foot or
on the ground where he couldn't throw
the football so that was our ultimate
goal
let's talk about tom brady and dominican
the difference that he's made for the
team i hear that they're making jokes
like it should be
tampa bay or tampa tampa bay what do you
think what can you tell us about tom
brady
tom brady and his leadership for your
team
i mean tom is an incredible leader and i
wish you guys could have been in a lot
of locker room at the beginning of that
game
about honor and the ability to
win this game and the p the people
around you and yourself will be honored
for years to come
and forever more and so it was exciting
to have a guy like that to be able to
have that type of speech and know he's
been in those situations before
so you really take it to heart and know
what to do and go out there and execute
and
i mean he's one of the most humble guys
and guys as continued
ultimate competitor so i'm glad he's on
my team and he definitely owed me this
one
and took care of business because he
took away a super bowl for me two years
ago
you know when dominican people talk
about your humility i understand that
you met warren buffett when you were in
college in nebraska that he's a mentor
to you
that you're expecting twins you got
married this is a good year
good year for you mr sue yes
this has been the jump man year for me
we got married on the 23rd
of may we got engaged prior uh prior
year and july 23rd
so hopefully these twins come around
march 23rd we're excited about them
and really uh just all my mentors uh
have been really
supporting me throughout all these great
times and tough times as well and mr
buffett has always been one of those
guys have
kind of held my hand and guided me
through all my uh
times and making smart decisions and
also just overall just good advice well
a super bowl ring tops it all off and
dominic and sue thank you so much for
being with us this morning
congratulations enjoy it i know you will
and congratulations on the twins too
yeah bravo i appreciate we're excited i
got some sleepless nights coming up yes
you do